hey guys Pete here a video today about
some new teaser material we got for Game
of Thrones Season seven a few hours ago
HBO changed the look of their Twitter
account and they released the first
official poster for Game of Thrones
season 7 so there's a poster and there's
an animation and the animation holds a
small secret in the image we can see it
is the night king with the date they
abbreviated Game of Thrones to geot
which is a little bit different but
overall it's not a very surprising image
instead it's a very appropriate image
for what we know is about to happen
we knew winter was coming at the end of
season six and with winter we're going
to be seeing the invasion from the north
that was hinted at way back in season 1
episode 1 now my reaction is is that
this is a confirmation that the war for
the dawn is coming but I don't think it
necessarily means that that will happen
in season 7 what's more likely and this
isn't just my idea I think this is a
collective idea of everyone who follows
this stuff is that everything will be
set in place during season 7 and then
season 8 will basically revolves
entirely around this war for the dawn
against you know that pits humanity
against the white walkers poster itself
is a static image but HBO also released
a animated version and this is where we
get a little bit of a teaser Easter egg
whatever you want to call it of course
whenever anything comes out for this
show the internet tears it apart and
checks it out and I did myself as well
and you can pretty clearly see an image
of Jon Snow the king in the north in the
night Kings I as it zooms out to create
the image that we have for the poster we
can see that Jon is pretty clearly
visible now what that means isn't
exactly clear but it's cool and it's a
nice nod and it's a pretty neat little
technical trick there I read a couple
conversations about their sin and some
people were seeming to think there was
more involved but
i zoomed in I looked at it frame by
frame you could see some of that in the
background right now all I can really
see is John's image and what looks like
a map probably of Westeros overlaid
across the eye John's in the pupil and I
feel like that looks like I'm Matt on
you know the the rest of the eyeball
there now you remember that when the
other trailer came out there was a big
hubbub about there being an image of the
wall in his eye and that maybe he was
watching me the wall come down so this
is a lot clearer right here I mean
there's no doubt about it if you watch
it slowed down and zoomed in there's
absolutely a person in there and if it's
not John snow I'm not sure who it is I
read someone thought it was benjin but
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
given that this is you know an official
release for the main series and that you
know if it's a northern man it's
probably John snow let's be realistic
here so let me know what you guys think
I know everyone's waiting for a trailer
I know I am too but this seems to be
lately how they put out photos one day
then they put out this so let's hope
that that means that the trailer is
imminent we've got 50 some days to go
until then the you know the season is
actually released so we should be
getting a couple of full-on trailers
with new scenes pretty soon I think so
let me know what you think do you think
that this is a sign that the war for the
dawn might be coming sooner or do you
think that the established theory that
you know season 8 will basically be
humanity versus the White Walkers and
things will move just in that direction
during season 7 what do you want to see
in the trailer you know the photos that
I posted in my last video the battle
singing looks pretty awesome so I hope
that we see a little bit of that in
moving pictures although a few been
filming my channel since you know the
last nine months you've seen quite a few
photos in my spoilers videos from the
sets when we saw a lot of the battle
stuff so is there anything in particular
you want to see I mean Nymeria would be
nice a little shot a Nymeria but
doubt they're going to drop that in a
trailer so yeah let me know what you
think are you hyped up from this or you
just like give me a trailer and what is
your wish list for future teaser
trailers promotional stuff that's going
to come out in the next month
now don't forget I do have a book
giveaway going on
it's for subscribers only if you
subscribe or are a subscriber and you
leave a comment you'll be automatically
entered to win a book and I've been
doing this for a while so when I reach
twenty eight thousand subscribers I will
pick one comment with the random comment
generator or picker I should say so make
sure you do that subscribe and comment
since we're doing Twin Peaks now it's
the subs are going up again so it's
probably going to hit 28,000 really soon
so if I were you I would subscribe and
comment here and I will let you know as
soon as I find something new about Game
of Thrones season something to talk
about thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon